hate on so when you think of a guys
night out what does that entail so when
I say drag race do you think of cars or
something else who's your celebrity
crush right now is it Neil Patrick
Harris Adam Lambert Darren Criss do you
use apps or hookups that aren't tinder
bumble hinge coffee meets bagel or
OkCupid have you ever held a flag that
has say more than six colors do you ever
hang out at bars that have memorable
names flaming saddle Adonis Oil Can
Harry's cubby hole Woody's bar man are
you bummed out as I'm that looking got
canceled are you a more of a fan of
Brian and Justin or Michael and Ben
would you say you're more will or Jack
are you more Margaret Cho or Kathy
Griffin you look like a market show have
you ever shared your razor with someone
do you own brightly colored briefs from
say Andrew Christian who's your favorite
youtuber it's a Davey wavey ello Stef
miles J will an RJ William Bell I would
you want to come to pride parade this
year it's a really great place for
allies and queer people did you ever and
jointly well during curse was on it
obviously what does the name alphabet
mean to you
you haven't happened to have seen eating
out 1 2 3 & 4 have you man I feel like
I'm the only gay guy at this office
sometimes so when you watch porn what
kind of words you type in the search bar
are you familiar with my friend Sean
Cody would you by any chance know who
Colby Keller is so dick yes or no
sure yeah tooth toothbrush brush no
let's not do that